สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีค่ะ
กลับมาเจอกับเราสองคนนะครับในช่อง
compreter
[เพลง]
วันนี้ครูอาร์ตี้
ข้างหลัง
สีสวยนะคะ
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์เป็นเดือนแห่งความรักครับ
อ๋อถ้าอย่างนั้นวันนี้วันอะไรคะครู
อาร์ตี้วันนี้ใช่ไหม
วันนี้วันจันทร์ครับวันจันทร์วันจันทร์นะ
คะอ้าววันนี้วันจันทร์วันจันทร์ดึกวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะที่ 13 ครับวันที่
136 ครับ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะอ่า 2023
ไม่ทันแล้วครับเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวไว้เปลี่ยน
คราวหน้าคราวหน้า
วันนี้ 13 พรุ่งนี้ครูอาร์ตี้
พรุ่งนี้ถึงจะเป็นวันแห่ง
ความรักใช่ไหมความรักนะคะวันแห่งความรัก
ก็เลยครูอาร์ตี้ใช้สีชมพู
เป็นวันแห่งความรักเดี๋ยวผู้อื่นดูอะไร
นิดหน่อยนะ
ครูเอ๋จะดูปฏิทินอะไรนิดหน่อย
ครูเอ๋ดูวันพระ
อ๋อวันที่เท่าไหร่
วันพระวันเสาร์หรือวันอาทิตย์ครับ
วันนี้วันพระครับวันนี้
ไม่ใช่
วันมาฆะ
อยู่เดือนหน้า
วันที่ 6 เดือนหน้าครับ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
วันมาฆะกับวันวาเลนไทน์หรือวันแห่งความ
รักวันเดียวกัน
[เพลง]
เดือนของคนไทยยังเป็นเดือน 2 อยู่ต้อง
เดือนหน้านี้เป็นเดือน 3 มาข้าจะเป็น
เดือน 3 นะครับ
แล้วแต่พระจันทร์นะคะนักเรียนแล้วแต่พระ
จันทร์บางปีก็อยู่เดือนกุมภาพันธ์บางปีก็
อยู่เดือนมีนาคมปีนี้อยู่เดือนมีนาคมใช่
ครับโอเคค่ะ
วันพระ
พรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้วันวันที่ 14
เราเรารัก
ศาสนาแล้วนะคะนักเรียนเรา
เวลาเราเลยไปแล้วใช่ไหมเลยเวลายังไม่ถึง
ครับนี่เลยอายุที่จะทุกวันแห่งความอายุ
ของพวกเรานะครับ
ก็เป็นวัยที่เป็นวัยที่คนไทยเวลาอายุเยอะ
ๆเราก็จะคิดถึงเราก็ชอบที่จะพูดที่จะดู
ฟังเกี่ยวกับธรรมะเยอะๆนะครับเพราะว่าตอน
นี้ก็มีลูกมีหลานเนาะไม่คิด
ช็อกโกแลตไม่คิดแล้วนะคะใช่ครับ
[เพลง]
เวลาตอนนี้ 4 โมงครับ
ตอนนี้ 4 โมงเย็น
หรือตี 4:00 นเช้าจะเอาตี 4 ใช่ไหมครับ
ถ้าเป็นตี 4 ตี 4 ก็แสดงว่ายังเช้าอยู่นะ
ครับอ่า
แต่นี่เป็น 4 โมงก็จะเป็นตอนบ่าย
4 โมงเย็นนะคะนักเรียนห้องเย็น 15 นาที
เป็น PM นะถ้าเป็น a  m จะเป็นตอนเช้าจะ
เป็นตี 4 ใช่แต่ตอนนี้ 4 โมงเย็น
15 นาทีใช่ครับ
โอเควันนี้จะพานักเรียนไปไหนคะวันนี้ก็
เราพูดเรื่องพระมาเยอะแล้วพูดเรื่องวัดนะ
ครับวันนี้ก็จะพานักเรียนไปแนะนำนะครับ
ว่า
ว่าเวลาเข้าไปที่วัดเนี่ยนักเรียนจะเห็น
อะไรบ้างเวลาเข้าไปที่วัดครับในวัดมีอะไร
บ้าง
จึงจะเห็นแต่ไม่รู้ว่าชื่ออะไร
ที่เรียกว่าอะไรอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรครู
อาร์ตี้ก็จะพาไปรู้จัก
หรือว่าอาคารต่างๆที่อยู่ในวัดนะคะ
อาคารก็
สร้างอ่ะค่ะที่อยู่ในวัดนะคะ
มีอะไรบ้างคะเดี๋ยวไปดูเลยครับอย่างแรกนะ
อย่างแรกที่จะให้นักเรียนดูกันนะครับนี่
ครับอันนี้ครับเวลาเข้าไปเราก็จะเห็นเลย
เพราะว่าจะเป็นอาคารหลังใหญ่อยู่ในวัดเลย
ครับ
อันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะวันนี้เราเรียกว่า
โบสถ์ครับ
เรียกว่าโบสถ์นะคะใช่ใช่ครับ
ใช่ๆครับ
ส่วนใหญ่โบสถ์ในวัดก็จะเป็นหลังอาคารที่
มีสูงสูงนะครับแล้วก็มีชั้นเดียว
ครับ
ใช่ครับจะมีรั้วอยู่รอบๆโบสถ์บางที่ก็จะ
เป็นรั้วเตี้ยๆแบบนี้นะครับอยู่รอบๆโบสถ์
นะครับไปรอบๆ
ตรงนี้มียกพื้นนิดหน่อยนะคะยกพื้นครับ
[เพลง]
ก็อาจจะไม่ได้ยกพื้นก็ได้เนาะได้เหมือน
กันแต่ก็จะมีกำแพงกำแพงเตี้ยๆรอบๆโบสถ์
เพื่อเพื่อให้รู้ว่า
พื้นที่ของโบสถ์เนี่ยมีขอบเขตแค่ไหนนะ
ครับมีบริเวณแค่ไหนพื้นที่เท่าไหร่นะครับ
กำหนดเป็น
รั้วเป็นขอบเขตบอกไว้นะครับ
ที่โบสถ์อีกอันนึงที่เขาจะดูกันคือข้างบน
เลยอ่ะข้างบนยอดโบสถ์ตรงนี้ล่ะครับใช่
เขาเรียกว่า
ตรงนี้เรียกว่าช่อฟ้าครับ
ใช่
[เพลง]
อยู่บนหลังคาโบสถ์ตรงบริเวณที่หลังคาตรง
นี้เป็นหลังคานะครับหลังคาจะมีตรงกลางแต่
ตรงหน้าจั่วเป็นรูปสามเหลี่ยมตรงนี้ส่วน
ตรงปลายแหลมตรงปลายแหลมนี้จะติดอันนี้เรา
เรียกว่าชอบฟ้านะครับ
นี่มีช่อฟ้าอยู่นะครับ
[เพลง]
เป็นอาคารที่ที่ทุกวัดต้องมีนะคะ
มีรูปข้างในโบสถ์ด้วยครับ
[เพลง]
ทำไมมีเหมือนประตูเยอะๆเลยค่ะหรือว่า
ประตูหน้าต่าง
ประตูจะมีอยู่ด้านหน้าเนี่ย
ด้านหน้า
บางโบสถ์ก็จะมีแค่ประตูอันใหญ่ 1 อันแต่
บางโบสถ์จะมี 2 ประตูครับ
[เพลง]
ก็มีประตูใหญ่นะคะถ้าประตูใหญ่เลยก็อาจจะ
มี 1 บานเข้าออกทางเดียวกันแต่บางบทก็จะ
มี 2 บาร์ทางเข้าแล้วก็ทางออกใช่ใช่ครับ
ประตูจะอยู่ด้านหน้าส่วนด้านข้างด้านข้าง
ที่แขวงเห็นตรงนี้ที่นักเรียนเห็นตรงนี้
นะครับด้านข้างนี่เล็กๆพวกนี้ 1  2  3  4
5 ตรงนี้เป็นหน้าต่าง
เป็นหน้าต่างนะครับที่ครูเอ๋ถามเพราะครู
เอ๋เห็นข้างบนของประตูกับของข้างบนของ
หน้าต่างดูแล้วเหมือนกันก็เอ๊ะมีประตู
เท่าไหร่อ๋อมีประตูด้านบนโบสถ์หลังนี้มี
ประตูด้านหน้า 2 บานที่เหลือเป็นหน้าต่าง
หน้าต่างก็ 1  2  3  4  5  5 บาท
เยอะเพราะว่าครับคิดว่าฝั่งนี้ 5 บานแต่
อีกด้านนึงก็อีก 5 บาท
ก็คือก็หน้าต่างน่าจะประมาณ 10 บาท
ต้องมีหน้าต่างเยอะหน่อยเพราะว่าประเทศ
ไทยเป็นเมืองร้อนใช่ไหม
ก่อนไม่มีแอร์ใช่ไหมใช่ไม่มีเครื่องที่ทำ
ให้เย็นๆก็ต้องเปิดหน้าต่างเปิดประตูให้
ลม
ถ้ามีหน้าต่างแล้วลมจากข้างนอก
เห็นลมไหมคะนักเรียน
เข้าไปดูข้างในโบสถ์กันนะครับ
นักเรียนเคยเข้าไปในโบสถ์ไหม
[เพลง]
พาเข้าไปดูในโบสถ์ว่ามีอะไรบ้างที่อยู่ใน
โบสถ์นี่ครับ
รูปที่ 2 เป็นรูปภายในโบสถ์นะคะตอนนี้เรา
เข้ามาข้างในแล้วนะ
ข้างในนี่ครูเอ๋เห็นพระพุทธรูป
ตั้งอยู่นะครับตรงกลางนะครับ
พระพุทธรูปที่อยู่ในโบสถ์เนี่ยเราเรียก
ว่าเป็นพระประธาน
ก็คือเป็นพระที่สำคัญที่สุดก็เลยเรียกว่า
เป็นประธานนะครับเป็นพระประธานนะครับอัน
ที่สำคัญที่สุดก็จะอยู่ในโบสถ์นี่แหละ
แล้วก็จะ
ตั้งเอาไว้สูงๆเนาะใช่ครับให้เห็นง่ายๆ
เขาเรียกฐานอยู่ด้านล่างนะครับ
แล้วก็ครูเอ๋เห็นเสาเยอะเลยใช่ครับเพราะ
ว่าโบสถ์เนี่ยส่วนใหญ่โบสถ์ของไทยเนี่ยจะ
ทำหลังคาสูงๆสูงๆขึ้นไปเพราะหลังคาสูง
แล้วหลังคาด้านนอกที่นักเรียนเห็นน่ะ
หลังคาจะใหญ่มากเห็นไหมครับพอใหญ่มากแล้ว
ก็จะมีน้ำหนักมีน้ำหนักมากเพราะฉะนั้นเสา
ก็จะต้องมีมีเสาที่มากพอที่จะรับน้ำหนัก
ของหลังคาพอหลังคาจะหนักพอหลังคาใหญ่
โบสถ์แต่ละที่ก็จะมีเสาสูงๆใหญ่ๆอยู่ข้าง
ในโบสถ์
แล้วก็ที่หลังคาแล้วเพดานครูอาร์ตี้
อยู่บนเพดาน
เรียกว่าอะไรคะอันนี้เรียกว่าเป็นโคมไฟ
ระย้า
เพราะว่าเวลาอยู่ในโบสถ์เนี่ย
ถ้าแสงมีแสงไม่พอก็จะสว่างไม่มากเราก็
ต้องมีโคมไฟนะครับมีโคมไฟเพื่อเปิดให้
ความสว่างนะครับแทน
แต่ถ้าเขาใช้ไฟธรรมดาก็ได้ใช่ไหมคะใช้ไฟ
ธรรมดาก็ได้เหมือนกันครับได้แต่เนื่องจาก
บางทีบางบทยังบดเนี่ยเขามีมีวาดรูปที่ที่
เพดานเป็นรูปกลมๆนะคะก็เลยใช้โคมไฟระย้า
จะได้เข้ากันกับรูปกลมๆจะได้มีความสวยงาม
นะครับ
[เพลง]
ว่าทำไมทำไมถึงต้องมีโบสถ์โบสถ์เอาไว้ทำ
อะไรครับ
[เพลง]
ทำอะไรบ้างครับในโบสถ์เวลาเราเข้ามาใน
โบสถ์เราเข้าไปทำอะไรกันครับ
แต่ถ้าคนทั่วไปนะคะเราก็ไปกราบไปไหว้ไหว้
พระประธานนะคะกราบพระแต่ว่าถ้าสำหรับ
สำหรับ
ผู้ชายเวลาจะบวชพระคือผู้ชายอายุ 20 ปี
ขึ้นไปแล้วก็คิดจะไปเป็นพระจมูกระบอบบวช
พระก็ต้องเข้าไปทำพิธีในโบสถ์
เรามีไว้สำหรับการทำพิธีทางศาสนาอย่าง
เช่นการบวช
แล้วก็มี
การสวดมนต์ใช่ไหม
จะเข้ามาพระสงฆ์อ่ะค่ะพระสงฆ์ทั้งหมดจ้า
จะเข้าไปทุกทุก 7 วันไหมทุกวันพระ
ใช่ครับ
สวดมนต์สวดมนต์ด้วยกันนะครับ
สวดมนต์ด้วยกันกับพระทุกๆรูปในวัดนะครับ
หรือส่วนที่ก็คือ
สวดมนต์นักเรียนสวดมนต์ก็คือท่องภาษาบาลี
นะคะ
ด้วยกันนะครับทุกอาทิตย์ละ 1 ครั้งนะครับ
ก็มามารวมกันอยู่ในโบสถ์นี้แล้วก็สวดมนต์
ไปพร้อมๆกันนะครับ
คือถ้าเราไปส่วนใหญ่ไปวัดเราก็อยากจะเข้า
ไปในโบสถ์แล้วก็กราบพระ
ต้องเรียบร้อยนะคะนักเรียนใช่ครับ
[เพลง]
เวลาเข้าไปวัดเราก็จะเข้าไปในโบสถ์เราก็
จะกรอกนะคะกราบคือกราบลงกับพื้นใช่
3 ครั้งนะคะกลับ 3 ครั้งกราบพระประธาน
แล้วก็
ในโบสถ์ก็จะมีมีสวยๆอาจจะวาดรูปหรืออะไร
สวยๆแล้วแต่โบสถ์ซึ่งไม่เหมือนกันนะคะ
มีอะไรอีกคะนอกจาก
นอกจากโบสถ์แล้วสิ่งที่เราจะได้เห็นชัดๆ
นะครับบางวัดจะมีนะแต่บางวัดก็จะมีเล็กๆ
นะครับอันนี้ครับ
[เพลง]
สีขาว
อันนี้เราเรียกว่า
เรียกว่าเจดีย์ครับ
[เพลง]
แต่ว่าความหมายไม่เหมือนกันนะครับ
เจดีย์นี่มีทั้งเล็กทั้งใหญ่เนาะใช่ครับ
แล้วก็มีหลายๆรูปหลายๆแบบนะคะมีหลายๆแบบ
นะครับ
คล้ายๆแบบนี้ก็เจดีย์สูงๆมียอดแหลมๆนะ
ครับขึ้นไปด้านบนนะครับมีทั้งเล็กทั้ง
ใหญ่เขาเรียกก็เรียกเจดีย์ทั้งหมดนะครับ
เป็นจริงมีอย่างอื่นอีกไหมคะที่คล้ายๆ
เจดีย์ที่คล้ายๆกันก็จะมีเป็นอันนี้อัน
นี้ๆเดี๋ยวถ้าครูอธิบายนักเรียนร้องอ๋อ
แปลว่าเคยเห็นเคยเห็นมีแน่ๆเลย
นี่ครับ
[เพลง]
คล้ายๆกันนะครับ
อันนี้เจดีไหมคะอันนี้เป็นเจดีย์ชนิดนึง
แต่ว่าเราเราไม่ได้เรียกว่าเจดีย์อ่า
อันนี้เราเรียกว่าอะไรคะเรียกว่าพระ
ปรางค์ครับ
สูงมากนักเรียนใช่สูงมากครูอาร์ตี้
ถามนักเรียนที่ดูแล้วก็ฟังเราอยู่
comment ข้างล่างหน่อยนะคะว่าใครเคยไป
ที่วัดทางนี้ใช่ไหมวัดอรุณนะคะ
ไปวัดอรุณแล้วก็ขึ้น
ขึ้นเดินขึ้น
ข้างบนของพระปรางค์นะคะนักเรียนคอมเมนต์
ข้างล่างหน่อยนะคะใครเคยขึ้นไปข้างบน
นะคะ
[เพลง]
แล้วก็เดินรอบๆๆๆอันนั้นดีกว่า
ไม่ได้อยากขึ้นนักเรียนบอกว่า
ครูที่เป็นเพื่อนกันบอกขึ้นนักเรียนขึ้น
ได้ตอนลงน้ำตาไหล
เพราะว่ามันสูงมากเลยใช่กลัวที่มองขึ้นไป
แล้วสูงมาก
ก็เป็นพระปรางค์นะคะบางวัดก็จะมีทั้ง
เจดีย์แล้วก็พระปรางค์นะคะ
ก็เป็นส่วนหนึ่งในวัดเนาะนะคะแต่บางวันก็
มีพระปรางค์ไม่ได้มีทรงที่เป็นเจดีย์ใช่
ไหมคะก็มีอย่างเดียว
โอเคมีอะไรอีกไหน
อันนี้ก็สำคัญมากครับเป็นที่ที่เวลาคนไป
เยอะๆเวลาเราไปทำบุญกันที่วัดก็ต้องมี
สถานที่ที่นึงที่ทุกคนไปรวมกันอยู่ที่
นั่นนะครับแล้วก็ทำบุญใส่บาตรไหว้พระเรา
ทำกันที่นี่ครับอ่านักเรียนน่าจะเคยเห็น
อ้าอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะอันนี้เราเรียก
ว่าศาลาศาลาการเปรียญชื่อเต็มๆนะชื่อเต็ม
ๆเรียกว่าศาลาการเปรียญอีกครั้งอีกครั้ง
อีกครั้งศาลาการเปรียญเราต้องพูดด้วยกัน
นะคะอ่า
คำเดียวกันเป็นสถานที่อันนี้ครับศาลาการ
เปรียญนะครับ
[เพลง]
เรียนศาลาการเปรียญยาว
ปลูกพูดยากพูดซ้ำได้ไหม
ถ้าพูดศาลา
ถ้าพูดศาลากลัวตี้ก็จะคิดไปถึงศาลาอัน
เล็กๆอีกแบบหนึ่งที่เป็นศาลาเล็กๆที่เรา
ใช้
หลบหน้ารถล้อรถเมล์นั่งคุยกันนั่งหลบ
ฝนหลบแดด
1 รอรถ 2 เป็นสำหรับ
ถ้ากรุงเทพฯบางวัดเขามีศาลาเยอะๆ
แต่ต่างจังหวัดอาจจะมีศาลา 1 ศาลาหรือสอง
ศาลานะคะแต่ถ้าศาลาการเปรียญก็จะเป็นศาลา
ใหญ่
แบบนี้เลยที่คนสามารถเข้าไปอยู่ได้หลายๆ
คนนะครับใช่แต่คนไทยต่างจังหวัดบางคนก็จะ
พูดซ้ำๆได้ว่าอ๋อเดี๋ยวๆไปทำบุญไปที่ศาลา
นะไปเจอกันที่ศาลาแบบนี้เราก็จะเข้าใจใช่
เพราะว่าวัดบางวัดมีศาลาการเปรียญ 1 ศาลา
นะคะ 1 ศาลาก็พูดศาลาได้แต่ว่าถ้ามีหลายๆ
ศาลาก็ต้องถามว่าสาระไหน
คืออันใหญ่แน่นอนมีคนเยอะๆอ่ะ
ครับมีอะไรคะ
[เพลง]
ส่วนใหญ่ศาลาการเปรียญเนี่ยก็จะเป็นสถาน
ที่ที่เรามาทำกิจกรรมหลายๆอย่างนะครับอาจ
จะเป็นกิจกรรมของประชาชนก็ได้นะเป็นคนมา
มีกิจกรรมนัดพบหรือว่ามาพูดคุยมาทำบุญกัน
ที่ที่ศาลาการเปรียญนี้นะครับอืมทุกๆ 7
วันนะคะนักเรียนคนไทยก็จะไปทำบุญที่วัดก็
จะไปที่ศาลาการเปรียญนำอาหารไปนะครับนำ
อาหารไปใส่บาตรพระไปทำบุญก็มาที่ศาลาการ
เปรียญนี้นะครับหรือแม้กระทั่งพิธีคนตาย
ก็อยู่ที่ศาลาการเปรียญก็อยู่ที่นี่ได้
เหมือนกันนะครับ
[เพลง]
ก็จะมีตอนทำก็จะไปทำที่วัดเลย
นะครับ
เห็นเห็นพระพุทธรูป
ที่ศาลามีพระพุทธรูปด้วยใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับ
แต่แต่ไม่ใช่พระประธานของวัดนะคะเราจะไม่
ได้เรียกว่าเป็นพระประธานเพราะถ้าเป็นพระ
ประธานเนี่ยต้องอยู่ในโบสถ์เท่านั้น
แต่บทกับศาลามีอะไรที่ต่างกันไหมคะบางที
ความใหญ่ใหญ่บางทีศาลาก็ใหญ่กว่าโบสถ์ก็
มีนะ
ใช่ไหมคะ
ใหญ่กว่าแต่แต่ไม่ได้สูงกว่า
ไม่ได้สูงกว่าแต่ว่าโบสถ์จะสูงสูงที่สุด
นะคะ
ศาลาบ้านบางทีศาลาก็จะบางทีศาลานอกจาก
ใหญ่แล้วก็
ยกขึ้นไปเป็น 2 ชั้นก็มี
ใช่แต่โบสถ์จะมีชั้นเดียวแน่นอนโบสถ์จะมี
แค่ชั้นเดียวศาลาจะมี 2 ชั้นมีชั้นบนชั้น
ล่างได้เหมือนกัน
[เพลง]
กำลังคิดกำลังคิดถึง
ต่อไปมีอะไรอีกคะต่อไปมีโบสถ์มีเจดีย์มี
ศาลาการเปรียญแล้วก็ต้องมีที่อยู่ของพระ
ครับ
เพราะว่าพระก็จะต้องมีที่อยู่นะครับเป็น
ที่ที่
จำวัดนอนก็คือจำวัดนะครับแล้วก็บางที
ประมาณนี้อยู่อ่านหนังสือนะครับอยู่เอ่อ
รูปเดียวนะครับด้วยความสงบของตนเองจะได้
ไม่ไปอยู่ปนกับพระรูปๆอื่นคนหลายๆคนมาหา
จะได้อยู่แบบสงบๆจะได้ปฏิบัติธรรมได้นะ
ครับที่นี่ครับเราเรียกว่ากุฏิ
ก็จะต้อง
กุฏิก็จะพระ 1 รูปใช่ไหมคะโดยปกติโดยปกติ
ก็จะ 1 กุฏิ 1 หลังเนี่ยเราเรียกเป็นหลัง
นะครับกุฏิเป็น 1 หลัง 1 หลังก็จะมีพระ
อยู่ 1 รูปนะครับเพราะว่าจะได้อยู่ด้วย
ความสงบหรือรูปเดียวอ่านหนังสือนั่งสมาธิ
ได้สงบไม่มีใครมารบกวน
ศาสนาเรียนเรียนว่าพระพุทธเจ้าสอนอะไรนะ
คะอาจเปลี่ยน
บทสวดนะคะก็ต้องอ่านหนังสือแล้วก็ต้องฝึก
วิปัสสนาก็จะต้องอยู่เงียบๆนะคะ
ก็จะมีกุฏิก็ต่างจังหวัดเนาะ 1 กุฏิก็พระ
1 รูป
[เพลง]
ถ้าเป็นกุฏิของพระที่อยู่ในเมืองนะครับก็
อาจจะไม่มีพื้นที่เยอะ
ก็จะไม่มีพื้นที่เยอะที่ให้สร้างกุฏิหลัง
ละ 1 รูป 1 รูปก็จะมีกุฏิที่เป็นมีหลายๆ
ห้อง
เหมือนกัน
ก็จะแบ่งเป็นห้องนึงก็มีพระอยู่ 1 รูป
ห้องหนึ่งก็มีพระอยู่ 1 รูปนะครับ
แบบนี้ก็เรียกว่าเป็นตึก
เป็นตึกแล้วก็แบ่งห้องใช่ๆ
[เพลง]
เพราะฉะนั้นก็เป็นสร้างเป็นกุฏิหลังใหญ่
เลยแล้วก็อยู่ได้หลายๆรูปอยู่ด้วยกัน
1 ห้องนะครับ
ห้องละ 1 รูป
[เพลง]
แบบนี้มาก
อยู่คนเดียวไม่อยากอยู่ไกลๆคนอื่นใช่ไหม
มีเพื่อนค่ะนักเรียน
ถ้าอยู่คนเดียวที่หนึ่งกุฏิรู้สึกเหงาหรอ
เหงา
เกินไปใช่ไหมครับ
มันสงบเกินไปหรอ
เอ่อสงบแต่
ชอบมีมีเพื่อนอยู่ใกล้ๆ
รู้สึกว่ามีเพื่อนอยู่ใกล้ๆก็จะอุ่นใจ
[เพลง]
บวชใช่ไหมคะเคยบวชครับ
ที่อยู่ในเมืองเพราะฉะนั้นก็จะอยู่กุฏิ
แบบนี้กุฏิแบบที่ติดกันหลายๆห้องติดกัน
หลายๆห้อง
ครัว
ที่อยู่ได้เพราะกลัวเตี้ยไม่กลัวผี
อุตส่าห์ไม่พูดนะ
เป็นผู้ชายแล้วต้องบวชแล้วก็อยู่อยู่กุฏิ
คนเดียวนี่คิดว่าตื่นเต้น
จะได้มีสติมีสติตลอดเวลาอุ้ยเสียงอะไรใคร
ทำอะไรอ้อเสียงนกเสียงไก่
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะมีเพื่อนดีกว่านะ
ครับก่อนนี้จะหมดเวลากันอ่ะเราพูดเล่นกัน
เยอะเดี๋ยวนักเรียนอีกที่นึงนักเรียนเข้า
ไปที่นี่นักเรียนจะต้องเห็นนะครับอาจจะ
สงสัยว่าที่นี่คืออะไรนะครับอ่าอันนี้
ครับ
[เพลง]
สิ่งสำคัญที่มันแตกต่างจากศาลาทั่วไปคือ
เห็นมีมีท่อมีปล่องขึ้นไปข้างบน
ปล่องตรงนี้ครับอ่าเวลาที่ใช้งานเนี่ยมัน
ก็จะมีควันออกมา
ตรงนี้เราเรียกอะไรก่อน
เราเรียกอะไรครับไม่ใช่ของซานตาคลอสมาใช่
ไหมไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่เป็นของ
ปล่องควัน
หมายถึงตึกนี้ใช่ไหมคะใช่
ครับอ๋อเขาเรียกว่าเมนอ่าเรียกว่า Main
ใช่ครับเอาไว้ทำอะไรคะครูอาร์ตี้เมนู
เผาเผาศพคนที่ตายแล้วนะครับสำหรับคนไทยใน
ศาสนาพุทธส่วนใหญ่นะส่วนใหญ่เวลาคนตาย
แล้วเราก็จะเอาไปเผาเราไม่ฝัง
ตอนนี้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ตอนนี้จังหวะนักเรียน
ตอนนี้นะคะตอนนี้แต่ถ้าสมัยโบราณ
ก็จะฝังเอ๊ะเดี๋ยวเผากับฝังนี่ต่างกันยัง
ไงฝังเป็นยังไงคะครูอาร์ตี้วาดรูปให้
หน่อยดิ
ถ้าฝั่งนักเรียนก็จะเคยก็จะเคยเห็นที่มี
มี
นะครับขุดหลุมลงไปบนพื้นดินนะครับแล้วก็
มีป้ายป้ายชื่อติดไว้ว่าเป็นใครแล้วก็ฝัง
ลงไปในดิน
มีโรงอยู่ข้างล่างใช่ครับใส่ลงแล้วก็ฝั่ง
ลงไปในดินแบบนี้นะครับ
ทางไหนก็กี่คนนอนอยู่ใช่ไหม
โอเคอันนี้คือฝังนะคะฝังแต่ถ้าเผาก็จะไป
ที่เมรุนะคะ
เราก็จะมีไฟใช่ครับแล้วก็เผาอยู่ข้างใน
นี้
[เพลง]
แล้วควันก็จะออกด้านบนนะครับ